bene tutti ragazzi perché questo noi di
io sono parigi oggi parliamo dei cazzi
miei
oggi parliamo di argomento un po cretino
però nel senso non è vero io ho scritto
quello nel titolo ma di quello parliamo
perché i gesti video qua sono proprio
parliamo chissenefrega del mondo
viva la vita allora oggi parliamo
ragazzi di che da quando è uscita la
faccenda di step nimes la quale non ho
proferito parola ma sapete tutti come la
penso quindi sempre dalla parte di
stefano è uscito fuori che essendo
stefano uno degli youtubers più
conosciuti in italia un sacco di gente
ha fatto due più due ha detto ma
scusatemi se stefano ha guadagnato
quelle cifre libertate tipo 1 come fa vj
che lo youtube con vestiti italia aveva
tutto il casino perché la gente prodotti
giova beh grazie mi è stata posta una
questione sono praticamente mi sta
arrivando tante domande che è la
seguente ma pari j
siccome oggi tutti coloro che hanno i
soldi li spendono gucci con fendi braida
perché tutti i vesti con gli stracci da
nonna praticamente perché nel senso la
gente non si capacita che come la
persona che guadagna come possa non
vestirsi firmata o comunque come cosa
non non strafare nella vita ostentando
diciamo in modo cioè in modo da far
vedere che uno i soldi in guadagna ecco
questa è la domanda che mi è stata posta
visto quando quando sono uscite fuori
quelle cifre gli hanno detto perché non
ti compri luci e colori
allora partiamo da un presupposto i
guadagni su youtube sono e questo penso
lo sapete già tutti perché l'ho già
detto i 1600 video diversi senza contare
le interviste addirittura che pure
quelle sono un miliardo i guadagni su
youtube non sono fissi cioè non è che
ogni mese uno prende todt no per un mese
uno prende 100 il mezzo dopo prende due
perché è il mezzo pubblicitario dopo non
c'è detto questo io non sono di certo
berlusconi non sono neanche l'ultimo
degli stronzi ecco diciamo mettiamola
così quindi
bravissima un po ma io ti amo e ti ama
chi sei
ai loghi iloveyou ti sposo anche se c'è
l'immagine di un gatto e ti chiami come
me sul citofono mettiamo sito studio
stan quando ci sposiamo chissenefrega
va benissimo e i love you say fan va
benissimo sei fantastico malizia quindi
partiamo dal presupposto che comunque
non sono berlusconi quindi otto ville
non è il rosso comprato molto detto ciò
potrei permettermi di prendermi i
vestiti firmati
specialmente nella generazione in cui ci
troviamo dove ci sono un miliardo e
mezzo di rapper che ostentano collane
d'oro e robe del genere tutti i
ragazzini si sentono un po abituati a
vedere persone che hanno successo
vestire firmate ok e quindi fa strano
quando qualcuno che è successo non veste
filmato ecco questa roba qua questa cosa
qua è generata dalla situazione in cui
in cui ci troviamo in questo periodo
storico quando si vedono i rapper che
c'hanno le collane d'oro come siete
fedez che ha 86 magliette supreme io
invece 86 magliette di robe di kappa ci
sono dei motivi perché al giorno d'oggi
con i social con instagram apparire è
all'ordine del giorno quindi le persone
vogliono farsi vedere la maggior parte
delle persone forse non sono tutti così
ecco io faccio parte di quella parte di
persone che nella quale alla padroni ne
frega na sega perché per me pagare 500
euro una t shirt solo perché c'è sopra
scritto supreme per me e buttare soldi
non fate vedere questo video a surreal
power perché sono avviene a casa e mi
prendo a schiaffi su rischio per un
sacco di magliette firmate dove a genova
perché mi piace vivere così e attenzione
io non critico chi fa sta roba me non me
ne frega niente ognuno spedito di come
vuole però mi ritrovo in una situazione
dove tante persone lo fanno e quindi io
devo trovare a giustificare non
giustificarmi ma devo trovare a spiegare
il perché io non lo faccio perché ognuno
di importanza delle cose la vede
a modo suo io ad esempio i vestiti
firmati c'è per me è un telecomando
questo vale un sacco perché ho iniziato
a fare video con questo quindi magari no
questa semplice camicia a quadri che
avrò comprato non so a 20 euro dai
cinema per me più bella di una maglietta
di sopprime più appariscente ok quindi
io non spenderei farà una maglietta di
super in più di 20 euro perché per me
quello vale cioè nel senso era vedo dico
pure quella roba e 20 euro c'è non è che
se uno pensa ai guai roma vale 500 euro
per me deve valere 500 euro ma prima le
sempre 20 euro quindi quando vedo
persone che vestono firmato su instagram
robe del genere a me non fa né caldo né
freddo come cosa quello che avessi non
ti rende più importante cioè il senso
non cambia niente
non ti rende più film questo è un mio
esclusivo pensiero il massimo che io ho
speso per un vestito è stato 150 euro vi
pare o 200mila non so
ed è la felpa quella con le tigri
ricamate che ho comprato in giappone
probabimente l'avete vista in qualche
mio video perché mi piaceva c'è chi la
guarda liceo questa felpa per me vale
200 e cioè io li spendono cedono perché
per me li vale poi non so chi l'ha fatta
se l'ha fatta a topo gigio
forse l'ha fatta louis vuitton me ne
sbatto le palle di chi l'ha fatta però
la bellezza di questa festa per me vale
200 euro e li spendo ma e li ho spesi
una volta è successo una volta è una
volta sola proprio farvi capire ora
invece ragazzi arriviamo ad una macro
questione è un po più importante
aggiungiamoci a tutto questo
il fatto che io sono tirchi o come
l'amore ci sono piemontese i piemontesi
sono tirchi nella scala tirchiaggine ci
sono i piemontesi al terzo posto al
secondo posto ci sono i liguri al primo
posto ci sono io quindi aggiudichi il
fatto che a me del della nel filmato non
me ne frega nulla al fatto che seppure
tirchio quindi un casino ci pensa 85
volte prima di spendere 50 euro per
farvi capire quindi no perfetto quindi
io ho proprio di problemi come persone
sono esagerato adesso partiti sono
tirchi ossia di natura sia perché ho
sempre ragionato in una certa maniera
in che senso youtube non paga niente
zero cioè io una volta si guadagnava un
dollaro ogni 1000 visualizzazioni
ok monetizzate oggi si guarda io almeno
sono sui 0,25 centesimi ogni mille
visualizzazioni
niente il fai diviso 5 rispetto a quello
che prendeva una volta perché youtube ma
come il web in generale un mondo che
cambia troppo in fretta e troppo spesso
sono la stessa cosa troppo in fretta
troppo spesso quindi riformulo è un
mondo che cambia troppo in fretta e in
modi troppo diversi per poterli
prevedere quindi io che cosa ho fatto ho
detto cerco di mettermi da parte il più
possibile perché un domani questa cosa
qua potrebbe cambiare potrebbe finire
youtube youtube potrebbe non pagare più
come prima
ci poteva essere un sacco di
problematiche che infatti sono successe
quindi sono stato previdente e ha dato i
suoi frutti questa cosa perché oggi mi
ritrovai a dover dire bravo me che ho
messo da parte delle robe perché da
domani perché faccia schifo perché da
domani potrebbe risorgere problemi tipo
questo e potrà iniziare ad ice 3 per i
corsi quindi oggi sono tranquillo per
questo motivo mi pare che gli ottavi
abbia proprio detto nell'intervista con
break in italy che è un po pentito del
fatto di non aver mai fatto neanche
mezzo placement perché poi vabbè ma più
lui per un motivo diverso data perché la
centralità del ben due prove che io non
ne sono sempre sbattuto le balle perchè
finchè non va a rubare se sei una
persona onesta però la gente
il processo culetto quindi diamo un po
tutto
vediamo un po tutto nero insomma dove
del nero non c'è però vuole un altro
discorso
comunque ho sempre cercato di mettere da
parte tutto il possibile per il futuro
ma non lo farei neanche se fossimo
miliardari come berlusconi non avrei mai
speso per di vestiti robe del genere
perché non è nella mia indole punto
questo discorso
adesso vi faccio vedere la felpa che ho
comprato ragazzi questa è la fede un
sacchetto in rotta per cucito a mano c'è
veramente figo e quindi quando ho visto
il prezzo detto mazza o ma chissenefrega
per me li vale tutti è veramente piego è
di marca ma è una marcata in giro se tu
lo dici dc ma che è però in giappone
abbastanza conosciuta ma chi se ne frega
cioè io non l'ho preso per quello anche
se fosse chiamata kakà bubu lavori preso
perché questa roba a me piace ok una
borsa di louis vuitton che vale non lo
so 2 mila euro e la guardia di cuba
questa qualità o 30 euro non di più
perché non li vale per me
di 30 euro o anche quando vedo persone
che l'hanno in giro che l'appoggiano
magari gli altri fanno week ton
io faccio ok una borsa da quando è
uscita quel casino di step di quindi
tutti meno che se fa vigeva quanto
guadagni perché non vestì firmato perché
non me ne frega nulla
oggi rapper fanno es spendo questi che
esce bla bla bla tutta roba lì ea me va
benissimo potevo le volete però io non
sono così io non ho intenzione di
spendere i soldi investiti o robe
preferisco spendere 2 mila euro per cosa
che ho fatto per un viaggio e farmi un
bel viaggio come quello che è stato
giappone è stato il viaggio più bello di
tutta la mia vita e avrei spesi anche
10mila per fare quel viaggio mio dio
dice milano proprio farvi capire perché
quel viaggio vale ancora di più di quei
soldi perché mi ha lasciato dentro un
qualche cosa che nient'altro ti dà
spero che sia piaciuto spero vi
piacciono queste chiacchiere che
facciamo perché è un modo come un altro
per sfogarsi picazio per avere
un'interazione con voi mi piace avere
questo tipo questo tipo di interazione e
figo perché si parla del più e del meno
delle cose in modo più nel modo più
tranquillo possibile iscrivere al canale
schiaccia della campanella cui arrivano
le notifiche dei nuovi video e noi come
sempre ragazzi ci vediamo al prossimo
video bel ragazzo
[Musica]